[Music]
you got like three feet of air that time
can i try it really quick
hello there it is nas and welcome to
another episode of rt essentials this
week we're putting an end to those
debates where someone says this is a wes
anderson film and you say is it that's
right these are movies that you thought
were directed by wes anderson but in
fact were not it's an honest mistake i
mean anderson is an auteur after all so
his work is easy to detect and even
easier to draw inspiration from now
we're not saying these directors are
just a bunch of clauses to a steve zeso
anderson himself is the first to admit
that he borrows from idols like kubrick
and ashby and these are just some
irrefutable similarities we find
fantastic and worthy of discussion
up first is jean-pierre janae's romantic
comedy amelie written by guillaume
lauren and starring audrey tatu now
amelie is the story of a young waitress
who conducts schemes that alter the
lives of the people around her building
a whimsical world of her own making now
these private escapades prove to be a
distraction from amelie's true quest for
love and soon she realizes she must take
charge of her own life
[Music]
[Music]
now janae pays tribute to the city of
love shooting in over 80 parisian
locations and predominantly working with
a cast native to france funny enough
whenever the film was shot on location
janae and the crew would clean the area
of debris grime trash and graffiti so
that the real setting would match the
fantastically stylized nature of the
film breathtaking work so why are folks
at parties saying amelie is their
favorite wes anderson film well for
starters it's amelie herself the quirky
and flawed protagonist that we're all
rooting for name a single wes anderson
film that doesn't have one of those
hashtag bill murray
[Music]
and what about that vibrant set design i
mean just like the grand budapest hotel
and the royal tenon bombs it makes you
just want to hop through your tv but
don't because i've tried and it actually
hurts many critics and film buffs do
consider jenae to be europe's equivalent
to wes anderson so i guess we'll let
this one slide for now
napoleon dynamite
do you ride the bus to school
no
i ride my bike what kind of bike do you
have it's a sledgehammer
dang
you got shocks pegs
lucky
you ever take it off any sweet jumps
next we have jared hess's napoleon
dynamite the one that put ligers on the
map now set in the small town of preston
idaho the film centers around an
alienated mouth-breathing teenager who
is having the worst day of his life all
thanks to being the preferred target of
school bullies now napoleon's
grandmother gets injured in a quad bike
accident so she asks uncle rico to look
after him and his brother kip the
cage-fighting son who neglects his
chores to chat online with babes all day
listen
what
tonight me and your aunt are gonna go
visit some friends and we're not gonna
be back till tomorrow we're getting a
little low on steak so i got lyle coming
over tomorrow to take care of it well
what's there to eat
knock it off napoleon make yourself a
dang quesadilla
fine
and having a strange dance routine in
the middle of all of this though maybe
not a typical anderson-esque treat is
just hilarious i mean it may be just as
dry and odd as any film by anderson but
where it differs is in how far they're
willing to go with their awkwardness
almost to the point of unpredictability
not to mention director jared hess had
john heater improvise the dance routine
to three different songs then he picked
the best moves from each and put them
into one routine and that is some next
level talent hey lyle
[Music]
nothing on their work
so let's add this all up shall we we
have an oddball protagonist who we've
established is an every anderson film
who is the target of bullies and
sounding a little like sam shakusky and
cinematic shots like this one of rico's
1975 dodge tradesman in a field and even
anderson might think that this is one of
his it's an understandable mix-up but
this one belongs to hes guys not wes
captain fantastic i am so happy
that our family is
together thanks for putting on this
feast
it's all local and um
organic and non-gmo so how did you kill
those chickens
with an axe or a knife
i
i did i didn't
have to kill the chickens i they
uh i it's a rotisserie chicken so you
buy it on it's already dead or cooked on
a thing
written and directed by the dynamic matt
ross captain fantastic is the story of
ben cash his wife leslie and their six
children who live off the grid nestled
deep in the wilderness of washington
state honestly sounds cozy and like my
heaven now ben and leslie have instilled
their beliefs in their children such as
thinking that all of western society is
fascist and that modern technology is
not to be trusted to paint an even more
vivid picture the family celebrates noam
chomsky's birthday instead of christmas
now in all fairness chomsky does
currently look exactly like santa claus
i mean it's uncanny sanji's just turned
eight by the way
the bill of rights
amendment one congress should make no
law respecting an establishment of
religion or prohibiting the free
exercise thereof or branching the
freedom of stop regurgitating memorized
amendments isn't what i'm asking for
just tell me something about it in your
own words
south the bill of rights be more like
china here at least we don't have one of
the searches we have free speech
citizens are protected from cruel and
unusual punishments that's enough
now thanks to their politically charged
and sheltered upbringing beaudevon kyler
vesper reliant zaja and nai display
above average intelligence but they lack
basic social skills now this becomes
apparent when ben is forced to take his
children into the outside world for the
first time following the tragic death of
leslie fun fact though matt ross had the
actors who played the cash children sign
a contract promising not to bring any
electronic devices to set and to keep
processed foods and sugars to a minimum
which again sounds like heaven to me
always tell the truth
always take the high road
i know
maybe it's day like it could be your
last
drink it in
be adventurous be bold but savory goes
fast
i know
don't die
i won't thematically ross touches on
controversial issues like mental illness
suicidal ideation think richie
tenenbaum's infamous bathroom scene and
his peculiar portrayal of the family
dynamic is quasi-anderson still just
because fantastic is in the name doesn't
mean it passes the west test
submarine
essentially i disapprove of bullying
jordana however seems to enjoy it in
moderation
i must not let my principles stand in
the way of progress i must be willing to
adapt
[Music]
this was the correct decision
this was one of those vivid memories of
youth that i would cherish when i was
old and frail
[Music]
straight into the hands known for the
channel 4 sitcom the it crowd richard
ayotty directs submarine a coming-of-age
comedy starring craig roberts and
yasmine page roberts plays oliver a
welsh teen in turmoil now his love
interest jordana invites him for a
secret snog after school mostly to make
her ex-boyfriend jealous which it does
and leads to a proper beatdown but
that's the least of oliver's concerns
for he's convinced himself that his sick
mother sally hawkins is having an affair
with her ex-boyfriend and recent
neighbor graham now oliver filled with
rage and confusion breaks things off
with jordana decides to get drunk and
vandalize graham's home like most angsty
teens the stakes couldn't be higher and
oliver believes that this is no doubt
the end and news flash it isn't the
bevans were having christmas dinner
early in case it was the last one they
had i hoped it wouldn't be because the
turkey was quite dry and the sprouts are
turned mushy and out of focus
this is crappy love
yes great thank you mrs bella this is my
last warning it's june
so i hear from my little girl that
you've stolen a heart
let me tell you if you're lucky enough
to find an angel
hold on to her with everything you've
got
ayawati does find ways to separate his
protagonists from the obvious comparison
of max fisher for one oliver falls for a
girl his own age and is noticeably less
self-involved and summary does use
flawed yet self-assured characters much
like in fantastic mr fox but that's not
strictly anderson let's be francis it's
the music choices drawing the parallels
take this scene for example where oliver
pops in a cassette and curls up in his
dreamy ocean bed if this doesn't have
all the finger-picking melancholic
threads that weave their scenes like the
one in royal tenenbaums where these days
plays at the bus stop then you can chop
my hand and call me margot i know i know
it was actually her finger everybody
relax
have you got the camera in the diary do
you have the pamphlet give me the camera
but in case that isn't enough the film
also features tenon bomb star ben
stiller in an uncredited role and it
uses distinct color palettes for each
main character not a selfish submarine
nonetheless an excellent picture eternal
sunshine of the spotless mind
who am i mrs hamlin right mrs hamlin i
must be about four
oh my gosh
so i'm serving salad and string beans is
here
peanut are you all right oh god i
honestly feel like i could clean up all
day listen would you hate me if i asked
you to clean some string beans no not at
all
god i love this kitchen
thank you so much
she's not looking at me she's busy
she's not looking at me
no one ever looks at me
i want my mommy
oh baby joel next up eternal sunshine of
the spotless mind presented by an
absolute dream team of talent writing by
charlie kaufman directing by michelle
gondry and performances by jim carrey
kate winslet mark ruffalo and kirsten
dunst only thing this film is missing is
a wilson brother i mean heck we'd even
settle for andrew now kate plays
clementine a spontaneous extrovert who
after a difficult breakup undergoes a
procedure to erase all memories of her
ex-boyfriend joel played by jim carrey
now once joel finds out about this he
decides to offer the same procedure and
in turn forget every woman he's ever
loved um is this procedure on amazon
prime asking for a friend you erased me
that's why i'm here that's why i'm doing
this in the first place i'm sorry you
you know me i'm impulsive
that's what i love about you
now the film is visually striking and
intricate and colorfully dances with
themes of pain love and loss and that is
where the bridge from gondry to anderson
gets crossed one example being
clementine's hair shifting with her
character arc starting with green as
she's first meeting joel then red amidst
her romance and then landing on blue as
she's post-breakup and re falling in
love similarly in the royal tenon bombs
anderson uses bright red matching track
suits to evoke the sense of urgency and
paranoia that chaz holds over his
children's safety now both directors use
warm or cool tones depending on the
emotional undertones of the scene and
they employ costume design as a
storytelling device do i know you
[Music]
do you ever shop at barnes and noble
sure
that's it
yeah i've seen you man book slave there
for like
five years now oh
jesus i would thought i would remember
yours it might be the hair
what might
it changes a lot the color
that's why you might not recognize me
eternal sunshine is a prime example of
an indie film that can rival the likes
of anderson with its beautiful
cinematography unexpected lead talents
and a convoluted yet awe-inspiring plot
and jim carrey and kate winslet really
shine in their performances hard to
imagine nicholas cage being considered
for the role prior to carrie but maybe
in some variant timeline now you don't
have to accept this as gondrys but let's
make sure we're on the same page about
that daft punk video i mean epic
little miss sunshine uh what happened
was i was a bit upset
so i said some things that i shouldn't
have said and i did some things that i
shouldn't have done and subsequently i
was fired from my job and forced to move
out of my apartment and move into a
motel
and
that's when you tried to well no
actually all that was okay what happened
was two days ago the macarthur
foundation in its infinite wisdom
awarded a genius grant to larry sugarman
and that's when
i
decided to check out early
jonathan dayton and valerie ferris
co-direct little miss sunshine written
by first timer michael arndt we meet the
hoover family as they pile into a vw bus
and book it to california where their
young daughter hopes to compete in the
little miss sunshine contest now dayton
employs a cluster of accenture
characters very similar to those found
in anderson films you got the overworked
mother played by tony collette her type
a husband a son who's taking a vow of
silence a suicidal uncle a heroin
snorting grandfather and of course the
adorable olive i mean what possibly
could go wrong
[Music]
gonna be okay
[Music]
[Applause]
now the most obvious comparison comes
from dayton and ferris's motif of family
dysfunction and how that dysfunction
progresses in a confined space on a
mission much like the search for the
jaguar shark in the life aquatic and the
himalayan quest in the darjeeling
cheryl limited cindy remember when olive
was here last month she was runner up in
the regional little miss sunshine well
they just called right now and said the
girl who won had to forfeit her crown i
don't know why something about diet
pills but anyway now she has a place in
the state contest in redondo
[Music]
and there's something about that
bright-colored vw bus that screams west
or does it scream hess screaming wes
screaming spokoli make up your mind as
geez
lost in translation
does it get easier
no
yes
it gets easier
oh yeah
look at you
thanks
the more you know who you are
and what you want
the less you let
things upset you
the next entry in our feels like wes
fest is lost in translation directed by
sophia coppola and starring bill murray
and scarlett johansson we travel to
tokyo with an aging american movie star
named bob harris who is there on
business shooting a centauri whiskey
commercial now harris befriends a young
conflicted newlywed named charlotte and
the two find solace in their unlikely
bond as they traverse a foreign city you
you want a whiskey
this is not whiskey this is iced tea if
you gave me a real whiskey
i need mysterious face attention is
mysterious mysterious i i think i know
what you want you want this right
i need more mysterious and uh more
mysterious yeah i'll just try to think
where the hell is the whiskey okay so
this one doesn't really scream wes
anderson but it does cast bill murray as
a flawed father figure akin to steve
zeso now the unlikely bond forged
between bob and charlotte should feel
familiar to all of us anderson fans out
there and like many of anderson's
trademark bad dads bob's love ability
comes from his desire to be a better
person it really takes a certain kind of
filmmaker to make seemingly undesirable
people seem somehow
oh you've been married oh thank you
two years
25 long ones
you're probably just uh having a midlife
crisis
did you buy a porsche
you know i was thinking about buying a
porsche
it's mildly safe to assume that any bill
murray movie post 1998 involves wes
anderson in some capacity right in fact
coppola enlisted anderson's help in
convincing murray to play the part of
harris and boy are we glad it worked
because the more murray the merrier oh
and when you spot someone at a karaoke
bar and a pink wig and trust me you will
make sure you thank scarlett johansson
garden state
[Laughter]
got any suggestions
what
you got any suggestions
yeah kick his balls
kick his balls
yeah but i don't want to like destroy
future generations of charitable dogs no
don't worry about it i get three
dobermans if i didn't give him the balls
regularly
i'd never get anything done zach braff
wrote directed and starred in garden
state a feature-length rom-com about a
young actor named andrew who returns to
new jersey after his mother passes away
now there he's confronted by his former
life and the overbearing personalities
he once sought to escape from andrew
meets a cagey an often cringy musician
named sam played by natalie portman and
the two establish a deep connection
we're not gonna make out or anything
what
i'm sorry i just like totally ruined
that moment and then it's just like
we're not gonna make out okay no no i i
hadn't planned on trying all right i am
so lame that was like
i'm
i'm sorry i forget i just said that i'm
that's dumb and
now andrew has all the self-absorbed
delusions of characters like eli cash
fused with the withdrawn emo glaze of a
richie tenenbaum but broff really hits
the jersey turnpike and heads out west
with his optimal use of classic rock
songs such as simon and garfunkel's the
only living boy in new york which plays
during an intense makeout session now
anderson is notorious for incorporating
the songs he loved as a child into his
work such as ooh la la by the faces
street fighting man by the rolling
stones and alone again or by the band
love which might be bottle rocket's
finest moment also note to self play
classic rock during a make out sesh
i heart huckabees okay don't start with
that magic blanket full it's not magic
it's just the way things are tommy you
and me in the air are actually tiny
particles that are swirling around
together look right here you see
okay look at the cracks between these
particles and the cracks we fall through
the holes of nothingness exactly because
that's what i just experienced upstairs
look closer there are tiny particles
connecting the larger cubes yeah and
then tinier cracks between the
connections and tinier connections and
even tinier cracks yeah but if you look
close enough you can't tell where my
nose ends in space begins because
they're unified
i heart huckabees is an existential
comedy directed produced and co-written
by david o'russell now it features a
top-notch cast that includes dustin
hoffman lily tomlin jason schwartzman
and i know what you're thinking but it
also stars jude law oh wait grand
budapest let's see mark wahlberg well
he's definitely not in any west anderson
films
[Music]
did you get it
yeah
[Music]
i did i felt it
it's hard to describe
very very good
your turn
[Music]
now
now schwartzman plays albert an
environmentalist who seeks to solve the
meaning of a series of strange
coincidences enlisting the help of
investigators bernard and vivian they
conclude that brad a public relations
manager at the retailer huckabees must
be behind albert's angst now the most
obvious nod to anderson is albert
himself who eerily feels like a future
max fisher and russell's offbeat
approach his eye for detail and his use
of a capricious score from john bryon
make this flick dangerously wessy so you
sold out the woods this new mall is
gonna be very eco-friendly i saved half
the trees did i sell out the woods
i don't know i tried to do some good you
know i saved half of them
brad i torched your jet skis
and my house
well just your jet skis spread to the
house i'm sorry
but maybe the two directors have been
mutually inspired by their close
friendship in real life or maybe russell
feels obligated to flatter anderson
after lying to him about liking the
royal tenon bombs either way russell
made the fighter and i mean what have
you done today
harold and mod did you enjoy life when
you were a child oh yes you were a
wonderful baby harold
do you think the sexual revolution has
gone too far
it certainly has
do you find the idea of wife swapping
distasteful
i even find the question distasteful
do you enjoy
last but certainly not least is hal
ashby's dark comedy drama harold and mod
and what might be the oddest pairing in
silver screen history step aside gustav
and zero now the plot centers around
harold a death obsessed 20 year old and
his blooming relationship with mod in 80
year old eccentric now mod teaches
harold to value his life and to see
things from a fresh perspective and yes
they go there hello harold can i give
you a lip
oh there you are madame
well you're not the lady who drove my
car off yesterday was that the one with
the sink christopher medal on the
dashboard yes well i suppose it was me
get in there were you also the one
who painted the saint oh yeah how did
you like that well i didn't oh don't be
too discouraged for aesthetic
appreciation always a little time
now anderson was two years old when this
film was released so there shouldn't be
much confusion there however ashby has
left an unrivaled impression on
anderson's work which can be seen in
taboo storylines like rushmore and music
choices like cat stevens anderson even
casts bud core in the life aquatic and
once said in regard to ashby's 1970 to
1979 films to me they are some of the
best movies ever made well friends that
concludes our list of movies that you
thought were directed by wes anderson
don't worry i thought they were too but
what makes a true wes anderson film
anyway is it his rousing set designs
like the belafonte and the life aquatic
or is it his tales from a youthful
perspective like max and rushmore maybe
it's his cinematic symmetry clever
composition and theatrical blocking or
it's his use of color all that color the
reds and the blues browns and yellows
pastels and khaki maybe it's bill murray
one thing's for sure wes anderson is a
visionary that is him and i am naz perez
and thanks for watching today's rt
essentials stay tuned because we got
some epic shows coming up oh and don't
forget to find something you love to do
and do it for the rest of your life
[Music]
[Music]
you